nate is with us in Pennsylvania hi Nate
how are you put up with yourself it's an
honor to speak with you today you too
what's up so I'm trying to plan out to
my future here I'm 25 years old and I
don't have any debt currently and I'm
with a girlfriend that I would like to
get married within the next year year
and a half and she has approximately
about 74 thousand dollars in debt
$65,000 or student loans and about eight
eight and a half hour a car loan what I
kind of want some advice regarding this
is that whenever we do get married I
expressed to her that I would like to
help her with his debt and together we
have about $33,000 in savings
she's a little bit reluctant to allow me
to help she's very humble and wants to
take this on our own but I know as you
have you know taught us that once we're
married it's a team and we like to
tackle it together what are some of your
advice and words of advice as to
allowing us to work together as a team
to pay off this debt after you're
married yeah correct okay so you pile up
a big pile of cash in there for the
honeymoon you pay it all off or pay a
big chunk on it one of the two okay but
that makes her uncomfortable because she
feels like it's our responsibility oh
well that's a nice thing does it mean
she's a good person she's not a parasite
she's a person of character and so
that's a good indicator that you got
that you got a good lady there but I
think the thing is I'm just real
practical about stuff even romance and
marriage and kids I'm real practical
about it and so I just look and say okay
what are the data points tell us and the
data points we know from married people
who become millionaires a very high
percentage of them in the 90 percentile
I forget the exact number I work
together and share everything they do
not have separate bank accounts and
separate lives and they do not pull a 1
I'm just trying to pull you down while
the other ones trying to pull you up
in other words team
work and unifying your decision-making
and unifying your money is a is a is an
absolute must from the data if you want
to become wealthy if you want to get a
level of financial security and so you
know I guess you could tell her that I
don't it's not real touchy-feely but of
course the other thing is this I love
the idea that when you share your
spending and you share and unify your
financial goals
you are truly becoming one jesus said
your treasures where your heart is and
so when we unify our planning for crisis
we unify our planning for the future we
unify our planning about our kids when
we unify we become one and so you know
Sharon and I've been doing this stuff
right for about thirty of the thirty
nine years we've been 38 years we've
been married we've been doing the
working it together and with high levels
of communication and not going against
each other's decisions and those kinds
of things and it is just drawn us so
close together that the other one we
know what the other one's going to do
she's a little more fear-based I'm a
little more anger based she's a little
more security based and I'm a little bit
more of a bold risk-taker but we know
that about each other and we know what
the other one's going to do and we know
we're going to do this together and it's
it's a huge blessing in our relationship
and it gets a huge indicator that we're
gonna be able to win with money and we
have so that's what I would tell her I
don't know that sounds are a romantic
but that's all the truth I know amen
thank you for joining us